vamos a hablar de uno de los conceptos
más fundamentales de la ciencia la
energía la energía definitivamente tiene
algún significado en nuestra vida
cotidiana podemos imaginar cosas que se
mueven o que están calientes o que son
brillantes y consideramos que son
energéticas pero de lo que quiero hablar
en este vídeo es una definición más
formal de la energía una definición más
científica y la definición más común es
la capacidad de hacer trabajo
la capacidad de
hacer
y voy a poner trabajo entre comillas
ya que la noción de trabajo aquí no es
la idea común de ir todos los días al
trabajo dónde vas a trabajar y se
trabaja de 9 a 5 y te pagan por ello
trabajo en física no es completamente
ajeno a nuestra noción cotidiana de
trabajo pero te voy a dar un ejemplo
solo para darte una mejor idea del
trabajo vamos a decir que tienes algún
objeto aquí y vas a aplicar una fuerza
se va a aplicar una fuerza en esta
dirección y la magnitud de esa fuerza
digamos que es de 10 newtons
aplicamos una fuerza en la parte lateral
de este objeto y al hacer esto podemos
mover el objeto en la misma dirección
que la fuerza digamos que desplazas el
objeto 10 metros después de que haces
esto el objeto se encuentra aquí
al hacer esto estás aplicando una fuerza
y esto está provocando el desplazamiento
de este objeto en la dirección de esa
fuerza diríamos que se ha realizado
trabajo y la cantidad de trabajo que se
realizó sería 10 newtons x 10 metros 10
x 10 es igual a 100 y las unidades son
newton por metro de trabajo 100 newtons
por metros ya que fue una multiplicación
y newton por metro ha sido definido como
jules que es una unidad de trabajo y
también una unidad de energía así que
esto es lo mismo que 100 jules o podemos
abreviar lo con una jota se ha realizado
cientos de trabajo al mover este objeto
lo que hicimos al mover este objeto es
considerado
100 jules de trabajo si movemos este
objeto el doble de distancia entonces
habríamos realizado 200 jules de trabajo
por lo que la energía es la capacidad de
realizar este tipo de trabajo ahora
veamos estas imágenes de aquí que
representan diferentes formas de energía
y veamos si podemos identificar de qué
tipo de energía están hablando y luego
pensemos en cómo eso se puede relacionar
con realizar trabajo si vemos el fuego
hay algunas formas evidentes de energía
hay energía térmica el fuego
definitivamente genera calor así que
tenemos energía térmica pero vamos a
pensar en qué es la energía térmica
realmente la temperatura de un sistema
nos habla de la energía cinética
promedio de las moléculas de las que
está conformado por lo que la energía
térmica realmente es la energía del
movimiento de estas moléculas nos habla
de que todas estas moléculas debido a la
reacción de combustión
en un estado excitado aumentando su
energía cinética y provocando que la
temperatura del sistema aumente la
energía cinética promedio del sistema
aumenta así que la energía térmica
realmente es una forma de energía debida
al movimiento y el término general para
denominar la energía debida al
movimiento
es energía cinética por lo que la
energía térmica realmente es una forma
de energía cinética también hay luz que
está siendo emitida eso también es una
forma de energía y la llamamos energía
radiante a esa luz emitida que es la
razón por la que podemos ver el fuego la
llamamos energía radiante muy bien
probablemente pienses que esas son todas
las formas de energía en este sistema
pero yo te diría que no
todavía hay otra forma de energía en el
sistema y probablemente es aquí en donde
se encuentra la mayor parte de la
energía
y esa es la energía potencial y donde se
encuentra la energía potencial pues se
encuentra en los enlaces del combustible
aquí tenemos la madera o el carbón que
alimentan el fuego y estos están
formados por enlaces carbono-carbono
tenemos estos enlaces carbono-carbono y
puedan estar enlazados a más carbonos oa
otros átomos y también van a estar
unidos a algunos hidrógenos así que
vamos a tener estos enlaces que están
almacenando energía y que tiene el
potencial de ser liberada si logramos
romper estos enlaces los electrones que
los formaban van a poder pasar a un
estado menor de energía o podrán
enlazarse con otros átomos y en el
proceso van a liberar energía que va a
ser energía radiante y energía térmica o
energía cinética y como sucede esto cómo
se rompen estos enlaces bueno es debido
a nuestra vieja amiga la reacción de
combustión donde tenemos oxígeno
y tenemos energía
necesitamos la energía para iniciar la
combustión es por eso que necesitas un
cerillo para poder encender una fogata
más estos enlaces carbono-carbono que
sería esta madera o carbón esto va a
entrar en combustión
bush tian
y va a liberar agua ya que el
combustible tiene hidrógenos va a
liberar dióxido de carbono y va a
liberar mucha mucha energía lo escribí
en mayúsculas
y vemos esa energía en forma de la
energía cinética de las moléculas y la
energía radiante emitida y la energía
potencial que se encuentra en los
enlaces entre estos átomos la llamamos
potencial químico o también la podemos
llamar energía potencial química
energía
potencial
química así que podemos creer que esto
es cierto la energía potencial está
siendo convertida en energía térmica y
energía radiante y hemos llegado a un
punto muy interesante de acuerdo con la
ley de la conservación de la energía la
energía no puede ser creada ni destruida
solo puede ser transformada de una forma
a otra y podrías pensar de acuerdo la
energía se está transformando de una
forma a otra pero cómo puede esto
realizar trabajo de la forma en que lo
he descrito aquí bueno pues la
revolución industrial está basada en
esto en transformar la energía de una
forma a otra y realizar trabajo una
máquina de vapor está basada en utilizar
la combustión para calentar agua y
convertirla a vapor el vapor se expande
y empuja un pistón para poder hacer todo
tipo de cosas cómo mover un tren por
ejemplo la combustión es lo que ocurre
en el motor de tu automóvil donde los
pistones son empujados debido a la
energía térmica generada por la
combustión
y eso hace que el carro se pueda mover y
por lo tanto realizar trabajo
aquí tenemos otros ejemplos este es un
relámpago y cuando vemos un relámpago
vemos que claramente hay energía
cinética tenemos electrones moviéndose
de la nube hacia el suelo y podríamos
decir que este de aquí es energía
cinética
energía
sin ética
y podrías preguntarte cómo puedo
realizar trabajo con eso bueno eso es
justo de lo que trata la industria de la
electrónica la corriente es el
movimiento de los electrones y la
corriente puede ser utilizada para hacer
todo tipo de cosas maravillosas podrías
tener un motor eléctrico como una manera
de realizar trabajo así que aquí tenemos
energía cinética y también hay energía
radiante gracias a ella podemos ver el
relámpago y esa energía radiante ocurre
debido a que el aire es bien izado y
calentado por lo que también hay energía
térmica conforme los electrones van
hacia abajo se está generando energía
térmica ahora bien de dónde viene esa
energía bueno tenemos toda esta energía
potencial que se empieza a acumular en
las nubes conforme el vapor de agua
aumenta y no se tiene muy en claro como
esto ocurre pero debido a la energía del
sol el agua se evapora y conforme el
agua se evapora y forma las nubes la
parte inferior de la nube se vuelve
negativa se vuelve más rica en
electrones y la parte superior de la
nube se vuelve más positiva entonces
tenemos estos electrones que realmente
quieren llegar hasta el suelo porque
conforme el aire cercano a la nube se
vuelve negativo el suelo se vuelve
positivo así que los electrones quieren
llegar hasta el suelo pero el aire no es
un buen conductor de electricidad así
que una vez que el potencial eléctrico
aumenta lo suficiente
esencialmente el aire es ionizado y
estos electrones se encuentran un camino
hasta el suelo y debido a que todo esto
está sucediendo se está formando un
potencial electrostático potencial
electrostático
y como sucede esto
bueno hay algunas teorías al respecto
algunas de ellas muy buenas pero no está
completamente establecido como esto
ocurre
de este lado tenemos un dibujo de un
clavadista haciendo un parado de manos
para caer al agua este es probablemente
el ejemplo más común de la energía
potencial siendo transformada a energía
cinética que podrías encontrar en un
libro de texto de física aquí arriba en
el trampolín este señor tiene energía
potencial debido a la posición en la que
se encuentra y es muy evidente que tiene
el potencial de caer y convertir esa
energía en energía cinética conforme va
cayendo en este punto la mayor parte de
su energía ha sido transformada en
energía cinética
aquí tenemos energía potencial energía
potencial y aquí tenemos energía
cinética energía
sin ética así que nuestra gran premisa
es que la energía es la capacidad de
realizar trabajo no puede ser creada ni
destruida pero puede ser transformada de
una forma a otra y todas las formas de
energía esencialmente podemos
clasificarlas en dos categorías en
energía potencial
y en energía cinética
y en esta última imagen te puedes
preguntar en qué forma está realizando
trabajo este señor
bueno te puedes imaginar que si hubiera
algún tipo de sistema aquí donde tenemos
una plataforma aquí y una polea y por
acá está unido a una pesa bueno si el
pre encara sobre esta plataforma no
caería tan rápido pero si él es más
pesado que esta pesa va a provocar que
la plataforma baje y la pesa se eleve
así que él tiene el potencial de hacer
trabajo gracias a la posición en la que
se encuentra eso es lo que este sistema
no se encuentra aquí para poder realizar
este trabajo